et mesdames et messieurs voici un pot
pourri des réactions de certains
nouveaux ministres on vous lance à
l'instant
je pense que nous avons aujourd'hui un
conseil des ministres qui est équilibré
et je suis très heureuse et très fier
d'en faire partie et faut tout ce que
nous nous excusions maintenant de la
tâche colossale qui nous attend je suis
ici pour représenter 8 millions de
québécois et québécoises et je suis ici
pour faire en sorte que les donneurs de
penser à partir des impôts des citoyens
dans des services ce qui signifie que
dans les quatre prochaines années et
demi je vais avoir une tâche très
difficile mais à laquelle je m'inclus à
partir de demain matin j'ai eu des
gestes qui ont été posés par le
gouvernement précédent qui ont brisé cet
ailier confiance avec les absorbent les
thermes nationaux et nationaux marlies à
bestiaux locaux et il faut rétablir le
lien de confiance sur des tableaux nier
qu'on vient ça veut dire quoi ça veut
dire les hachures et nous présente les
termes et en même temps de les laisser
faire leur travail nous avons pris
l'engagement de déposer un projet de loi
sur la question de la neutralité de
l'état un projet de loi qui va
s'inspirer des travaux du comité oui
mais qui ont été déposés un peu plus tôt
cette année alors on va prendre le temps
évidemment de préparer tout ça et on va
également prendre le temps de consulter
les populations
vous venez d'entendre stéphanie vallée
députée de gatineau c'était une des
surprises sans contredit de ce conseil
des ministres michel sébastien bonsoir à
vous deux je commence avec vous ou
michele des choses qui vous ont
particulièrement surpris comment vous
oui madame valais c'est une surprise
personnes l'attendaient à la justice ni
même au conseil des ministres d'ailleurs
quand on parlait de quelqu'un dans
l'utah ouest c'est plutôt maryse
gaudreault qui était la personne qu'on
compte densifier donc c'est une surprise
monsieur poëti au transport et à
montréal c'est aussi une surprise
monsieur bolduc qui
hérite de tout le bloc de l'éducation
pas seulement les primaires secondaires
mais aussi l'enseignement supérieur
c'est aussi une surprise je pense qu'on
a voulu le soustraire mon dieu à la
tutelle de gaétan barrette s'arrêter un
ménage assez difficile à conduire mais
sur le fond sur le message que monsieur
couillard vous l'envoyer avec son gros
trio économique ça il n'y a pas vraiment
de surprise là sinon que dans son
discours il a peut-être appuyé sur le
crayon encore plus fort mais dans la
mesure où là il nous annonce du nom des
temps plus difficiles que ceux dont tu
parles en campagne électorale ces
bases-là je n'ai pas manqué un point de
presse lors de cette campagne électorale
et sauf erreur moi j'ai souri j'ai noté
en tout cas que le premier mais c'était
beaucoup plus
affirmatif dans dans la route qui a ri
qui sera difficile car il n'avait pas de
sens tout à fait comme ça dont il
n'avait pas d'idée sur le même ton
indiqué mêmes mots en effet on sentait
qu'il y avait des décisions difficiles à
prendre dans la mesure où en campagne
école il avait promis de couper pour 1
milliard 300 millions un peu dans les
temps sauf que là on a l'impression
qu'il veut aller au delà de saïx
s'apercevant parce qu'on nous laisse
miroiter un trou budgétaire s'apercevant
qu'il y aura un autre trou budgétaire de
800 millions de dollars il y aura des
décisions encore plus difficile à
prendre finalement et le ton en effet
vous avez raison est plus affirmatif
maintenant c'est normal il commence la
première année de son mandat de quatre
ans c'est le moment pour avoir ce genre
de ton là et c'est le moment pour faire
des compressions vous voyez la photo de
famille à l'écran on a deux choses que
je vous demandais d'abord le nombre de
femmes 8 sur 26 et aussi le nombre total
de ministre sébastien sur le nombre de
femmes jeunes a déçu certains oui
monsieur client avait en campagne
électorale promis une jaune paris tech
2-0 - 40 % de femmes il est à 31% alors
ce qu'on nous explique ce qu'est avec 18
députés femmes s'étaient pratiquement
impossible d'avoir la zone paritaire
d'atteindre 40 % de femmes au conseil
des ministres c'est à vous de prendre
cette explication et de l'accepter ou de
la rejeter le fait est qu'il n'y a que
huit femmes dans ce conseil des
ministres et sur le nombre c'est
relativement standard un peu plus
peut-être un ou deux de plus que jean
charest à l'époque trois de plus que
paul et non mais ce qui m'a davantage
évidemment le nombre de femmes mais les
fonctions qu'on leur donne et il ya
personne dans ce gros pull qui est
vraiment a titré aux as que monsieur
couleurs at-elle livré à faire les
affaires économiques d'abord c'est un
beau hislop se gouverne ophrys thériault
comment ils jouent un rôle important
mais pas exactement quand on disait ça
prend un gouvernement libéral pour soi
qui fait des vraies affaires on pensait
pas la justice par la sécurité publique
là on pensait d'abord aux finances
publiques à la création d'emplois à la
santé à l'éducation de tous les
ministères économiques y compris les
petits ministères délégués il n'y a pas
une seule femme qui en occupe alors si
monsieur client voulait rompre avec
l'époque soirée belle façon de le faire
donc les vraies affaires vous dit michel
c'est les gars qui s'en occupera qu'on
voit la photo d'hélène david qui sera
une nouvelle venue ministre la culture
des communications et responsable la
protection de la promotion de la langue
française monsieur couillard avait enfin
un petit mea culpa vers la fin de la
campagne en disant peut-être son exemple
lors du deuxième débat était pas très
heureux c'est que je suis les employés
doivent être bilingues sur les chaînes
de montage
est ce qu'il a à en mettre un peu plus
que ce qu'ils croyaient lui-même pour
dire aux québécois je m'en occupe du
français selon eux il y en a promis
beaucoup aujourd'hui dans la
l'appellation de la ministre on parle de
la ministre responsable de la protection
et de la promotion de la langue
française de tout temps c'était le
ministre ou le ministre responsable de
la charte de la langue française c'est
comme si cette mini cela n'allait pas
s'occuper de la charia ces mails et oui
la loi si on la laisse opérer comme elle
est maintenant mais on n'y touche pas
mais madame david et l'arrivée en poste
et déjà elle est interpellée par les
deux partis d'opposition la cac qui est
le parti québécois qui disent il faut
mieux protéger le français il faut faire
avancer le français alors que la ligne
de pensée de que les clients c'est de
dire on a les outils nécessaires avec la
loi 101 pourvu qu'on les applique la loi
ça on n'a pas besoin d'aller plus loin
que la loi 101 donc elle aura un défi
elle je pense à la période de questions
lorsqu'il sera question france je vous
entendent avant de vous laisser aller
sur michel barrette peter barrett à la
santé moi partout quand j'ai fait des
vox pop avec des citoyens on me parlait
de la santé sinon en premier en deuxième
ça arrive est extrêmement rapidement
comme préoccupation il ya pas beaucoup
de temps pour faire ça marque vraiment
même si ce gouvernement majoritaire les
gens veulent être soignée rapidement
quand sont malades ils veulent en avoir
pour leur argent on est les plus taxés
en amérique du nord dit on en tout cas
notre fardeau fiscal est très élevée on
veut en avoir pour notre argent c'est
pour ça que monsieur bart est tout à
l'heure en conférence de presse didier
il ya deux aspects ya le financement et
puis il ya la dispensation de soins et
lui il va devoir conjuguer les deux
connaissent sûrement avec les moyens
qu'ils souhaiteraient avoir et il va
falloir peut-être qu'il demande à ses
anciens copains de la fédération des
médecins spécialistes de rené goscinny
la femme chef doute absolument pas que
monsieur khouya mets sucrés à monsieur
barrette n'hésitera pas
à écraser quelques orteils que ce soit
que ce soit ses anciens collègues
bouleverser ou bousculer devrais je dire
les administrations des états qui sont
sa marque il veut faire sa marque et
bien honnêtement on le connaît on
commence à connaître un peu s'il lui
arrive pas à brasser ça y'a pas grand
monde tu vas pouvoir y arriver mais il
va peut-être et je crains pour lui que
ce soit le cas se heurter au mur
budgétaire qui avait eu raison déjà de
jean rochon souvenez vous quand il avait
voulu faire son virage opératoire quand
l'argent n'y est pas que voulez vous il
n'ya pas grand chose assez dingue vous
concluez merci beaucoup monsieur par
l'expression mur budgétaire je pense que
ça résume bien cette journée-là ce qu'a
voulu nous dire le premier ministre un
mur budgétaire et c'est pas
nécessairement de surprise parce que ça
c'est facile à dire mais entre il ya une
réalité qui tu es mais j'écoutais votre
entrevue avec monsieur l'état ils se
réservent quand même là la possibilité
de prendre un petit peu le temps pour
franchir le mur ben c'est ce que j'ai
noté aussi mais y est prudent il n'y
arrive pas ce que j'ai pas déplaire dit
les quatre ont légué budgétaire c'est
pas une religion en allégeant
obligations et on va voir ce que le
vérificateur général va la couvrir
messieurs merci beaucoup alors c'était
l'analyse de ce cabinet premier conseil
des ministre philippe couillard merci
merci au revoir